[Música]
aquí
todavía no nos hemos dado cuenta pero
desde hace al menos 500 años estamos
unidos en un profundo letargo conceptual
creíamos que copérnico nos había
despertado cuando dijo que el sol no
gira alrededor de la tierra sino que es
nuestro planeta el que gira alrededor
del sol hoy sabemos mucho más el sol
tampoco es el centro del universo ya que
hay miríadas de soles repartidos en
miles de millones de galaxias pero
seguimos tan dormidos como en tiempos de
copérnico
todavía pensamos que el universo gira en
torno al ser humano al que consideramos
la obra suprema de la evolución cósmica
la realidad es que no solo la tierra la
vida y el ser humano están evolucionando
sino también que en el universo se está
desarrollando un proyecto evolutivo de
dimensiones cósmicas del que
desconocemos casi todo
actualizando el discurso de copérnico
podemos afirmar incluso que el universo
no ha surgido para posibilitar la
evolución del ser humano sino que tiene
su propia dinámica evolutiva de la que
nosotros suponemos que formamos parte
sin embargo vivimos creyendo que el
universo gira en torno a nosotros que
tenemos el derecho a ocuparlo y
colonizarlo en nuestro beneficio sin
tener en cuenta ni comprender siquiera
la dinámica que rige la evolución
universal
esta percepción tiene consecuencias
hemos provocado la mayor crisis
planetaria desde que el homo sapiens
puebla la tierra por eso sabemos que si
queremos sobrevivir a esta crisis
tenemos que salir del espejismo
antropocentrista en el que seguimos
plácidamente dormidos
debemos ser capaces de contemplar la
evolución universal desde fuera de
nuestra mentalidad humana
y de comprender también la lógica si es
que la hay que rige la evolución del
universo pero hay algo más
un tercer espejismo nos atrapa todavía
es más sutil y profundo pero no menos
contundente el ser humano tampoco es el
centro de sí mismo
la ciencia nos alerta de algo
significativo nuestra personalidad es
una creación cerebral que cumple un
cometido evolutivo temporal
pero en nuestra ingenuidad la hemos de
edificado y nos hemos convertido en los
dioses del universo
si queremos ser consecuentes con estas
constataciones debemos explorar otra
forma de entendernos a nosotros mismos
si queremos descubrir nuestro papel en
el universo
la ciencia nos aporta importantes pistas
lo que hemos aprendido después de
copérnico nos ayuda a mirar de otra
manera al universo y a nosotros mismos
lo primero que hemos descubierto es que
hay algo que nos une con el universo
detrás de la dinámica cósmica hay un
atractor extraño una fuerza hipotética
que causa la evolución y el desarrollo
de los organismos
ese impulso seguramente está también
dentro de nosotros podemos reconocerlo
porque nos sacó de las cavernas
prehistóricas y nos ha llevado hasta la
luna y mucho más allá si miro para atrás
en el tiempo de mi propia vida también
puedo reconocer ese impulso que me
acompañó toda mi infancia y juventud hoy
me permite compartir esta reflexión
hay otro aspecto del universo que
seguramente compartimos también
la forma de trascender el tiempo
el universo no perdura en sus formas ya
que galaxias estrellas y planetas están
sujetos a la vida y a la muerte pero
lleva viviendo más de 13 mil millones de
años gracias a ese impulso o atractor
extraño que está detrás del big-bang
como compartimos ese impulso tal vez
podamos también aspirar a una forma de
existencia más allá de la materia
orgánica que es la que al igual que
soles y planetas está sujeta a la vida
ya la muerte
que la materia sea casi inmortal como
dicen los físicos es una pista que
alienta esta posibilidad también al
haber descubierto que la conciencia
puede ser independiente del cerebro
sorprendentemente estas constataciones
coinciden en el tiempo con el singular
momento que atravesamos como especie la
civilización se nos escurre entre los
dedos ante la agonía del planeta
esta coincidencia nos sugiere que el
primer paso para sobrevivir a este
momento sería superar el
antropocentrismo en el que estamos
atrapados
eso significa que si queremos sobrevivir
como especie tenemos que redefinir
nuestra comprensión del universo nuestra
visión de la evolución y la percepción
que tenemos de nosotros mismos
es un salto cultural que copérnico no
pudo ni imaginar pero que seguramente
nos situará en otro momento crítico de
la evolución humana
nos abrirán nuevos horizontes que
explorar solo perceptible si somos
capaces de contemplar el mundo y el
universo desde una atalaya que está más
allá de nosotros mismos
y seguramente también si en el pasado y
en cualquier otra parte del universo
otras civilizaciones dieron ese salto
cultural sería tal vez el momento de
percibirlos porque compartimos la misma
mirada que lo hace posible
y nosotros por fin abrimos tal vez
encontrado el camino que nos puede
resolver la crisis planetaria en la que
estamos porque nos comprendemos mejor a
nosotros mismos y lo que significamos
para la evolución del universo
no temamos por nuestro futuro porque
como decía carl sagan en el cosmos no
hay ningún sitio que esté libre del
cambio